we saw that that article today I just
tweeted it earlier and it's like we they
the Republicans just stopped a bill that
included the Democrats trying to figure
out ways to pay Chinese interest and
their corporations it's like why are we
bailing out Chinese businesses with our
stimulus packages the Republicans are
like whoa why is this in this bill we're
gonna we're gonna squash this so it's
like it's showing it's the mask is
slipping we're starting to see more and
more of reasons why they want us to be
fighting each other they made big
investments baby yes that was Nancy
Pelosi is net worth I have no idea with
her husband her husband made most the
money I think her personal net worth
would fall around like 16 million I was
reading an article about it but with her
husband serving the people she's sure
yeah but that's mostly her husband yeah
I think she's like an heiress or
something you know like oh great I could
be wrong well she certainly acts like it
yeah I mean all of our politicians are
super rich I wonder what a o'seas net
worth is by now you know cuz I wonder if
she's making money off this what she's
doing she's got a luxury apartment in DC
okay maybe or maybe you know she wanted
to raise so maybe she's not really
making that much money all finest knees
just do it I love a good sneeze Nana
okay so I think a lot of these I think I
think a lot of these uh look as a lot of
insider trading that goes on definitely
now I don't know who's doing what or why
but I'm willing to bet a lot of them the
plain insider trading right yeah so I'm
willing to bet that over time you've had
a lot of people who are super rich work
in government could see the writing on
the wall hey man China's making moves
why fight it man we can week you mean I
can get a stake and wear these big old
factories in China do it and now they've
got money tied up you know I don't know
exactly but my here comes trump going
you know what we're gonna tear off this
we're gonna bring manufacturing back
we're not gonna let illegal immigrants
take the jobs that should be American
jobs so the money that people are paying
is gonna go into America and stay in
America and we're gonna make America
great and now I was on there like but my
interview international you know like
you know the Pember the Panama papers
is that when China was trying to make
their own there's a bit now there was a
bit no the Panama Papers was a bunch of
documents showing that really wealthy
Americans were hiding money offshore
basically and then like I think I think
somebody involved in it like turned up
dead and then it just disappeared from
the news cycle so as I bring it up I'm
gonna make sure I keep an eye out the
window and yeah let's sleep with one eye
open is that well yeah all the rich
people had money stocked up in crazy
places and that was funny when a bunch
of celebrities had to like justify it
was my accountant they stayed I have no
idea sure you do but think about what
this means now if you had a bunch of
money overseas in various ways and Trump
is trying to shore up national borders
and bring back jobs here you know that's
a threat so it's no surprise that a lot
of these ultra wealthy individuals hate
Trump it's no surprise to me the never
Trump errs are like high-profile wealthy
political consultants who are also
shocked oh wow that's what they're doing
bottom dollar is gonna be affected and
now look at it this way you've got the
populist left who hate the Democrats and
the populist right who love Trump and
who are that who are the most angry
people well it's fair to say a lot of
the far left us are angry I think they
actually hate the Democrats more than
they hate Trump maybe they do they're
not talking about Trump I mean when you
when you look at who they're complaining
about who they're fighting they're
fighting to take ground in the
Democratic Party their key focus isn't
I'm gonna run against the Republican
it's I'm gonna run against the
Democratic Party the Justice Democrats
they're their principle opponents or
other Democrats you know I mean yeah so
like when AOC is is doing her campaign
she's targeting another Democrat not a
Republican well it's also as you said
though they're they're they're not
fighting against other Democrats and
their zones their districts are really
people walk in and hit the D button well
that's that's like the establishment
right right but the far left is actually
fighting those people so we just had
what was the guy's name in in Kentucky
Booker yeah Booker was beaten by McGrath
yeah so it's progressives fighting the
moderates the Democrats are in a civil
war right now right right yeah so you
know I don't know yeah that's that
that's that there the way I see it as
the wealthiest like Pelosi
the establishment crony politicians are
throwing everything gel's every single
scandal they can at Trump even Mitt
Romney voted against drinking about it
yeah so here's what here's one of the
ways I kind of feel about it you have a
lot of these Republicans who acquitted
Trump because they they know you know if
they go up against them they lose
reelection they lose more than just make
maybe potential investments the
Democrats just absolutely hate Trump and
go after them wholeheartedly but then
you see people like Mitt Romney - these
are the old crony establishment types
they hate Trump and I wonder what it is
what's the difference between you know
these people
perhaps it's the size of their
pocketbook yeah I think so I wonder I
wonder if that matters at this point you
know we got a cat in the table he's
doing it he's really polite actually
he's under the camera under the camera
kept his tail down so there's an article
going around that says you know be where
the fourth of July yeah talks about all
of the crazy things that are going on
like gold is spiking real estate in
Montana is spiking yeah like clearly so
what did someone tweet someone tweeted
like the people who have the connections
and are in the know seem to know
something
yeah know something I'm like oh yeah
we're definitely glad we're doing that
but is it now or is it November I mean
November's gonna come and then
everything's gonna go back to normal
because you think yeah because I mean
when was the last time there was civil
unrest four years ago when was that what
do you mean before the last crazy riots
was 1992 whether there's been non-stop
civil unrest for the past four years
mm-hmm since Trump got elected with the
Battle of Berkeley like three or four
times you had the fights in Portland I'm
not saying that that life hasn't been
crazy for since like no no no 2010 when
the SJW started yeah going crazy
reemerging coming out of the sewers in
New York the chud's cannibalistic
humanoid underground dwellers yeah it's
an 80s movie yeah yeah yeah I remember
seen that of the block boss
I was like it'd I don't know what it was
but then family guy made a reference to
it so now I remember it nice but uh good
old no my guy there there's been an
escalation of tension and violence since
Trump got elected well know before mean
we've talked about this it's like duh
because all these interests that they're
trying to protect are being shattered
so you think because the status quo is
being changed so do you think Trump's
gonna lose no I don't so then why would
it go back to normal because they know
that they I mean it's he's he's in it
for another four years so they have to
start focusing on the next four years I
you know after that point I don't know
will the far left didn't work what are
they gonna try it they're gonna they're
trying to draw up more they're claiming
it's working for China now that's the
most ridiculous is have they ever heard
him talk at all that's a response I was
like if you heard any of his speeches
you to understand that he has an issue
with China and China thank you yeah
that's like it's it's very clear they
don't care what he says it doesn't
matter what he says it's not about what
he says it's about what he stands for
yeah
was he stand for America he stands for
making and like making America great
again is his slogan I mean I I don't
like the again part because I think that
always great no no look I I love America
I love being America I'm proud to be an
American I think we can make it better
than ever and that's what it should be
it should just be make America better
than ever yeah if that's what I mean
it's we've only gotten better work like
we've had we create civil rights we
created all these naba like where we
where we started
where if slavery was the norm to where
we are now it's like we've come a long
way let's keep let's keep progressing
forward and not tear it all down they're
trying to tear it all down how about you
order some mAb hats make America better
make America better yeah I think we have
and that's why I thought I liked the the
magg make America greater yeah great huh
yeah
make America greater well now he has
keep America great America needs still
needs some some help my issue I think I
think Trump's we can be better
Trump responds to emotionally too easily
he gets baited he really does there's a
lot of things he doesn't get made it
there's a lot of clever things he does
mm-hmm but when they insult him it's
like what does he do he he go he goes
after I I know it's true
you know there's a there's a video
getting shared around it from Russell
Brand he's great I only saw a small clip
of it I haven't watched this one but
someone sent it to me to watch it was
saying like what what did it say like
are we under estimating Trump or
something like that
I'm not sure but this is there's a
really great part where he shows Trump
talking and then Trump makes a joke and
everyone busts out laughing and then
Russell Brand says these people are
genuinely laughing he's like then it's
not canned it's not like a speech it's
like they're actually laughing with him
they're loving it yeah and he's funny
he's an entertainer man yes he knows
what he's doing yeah tell you this man I
went to the White House when he did that
thing and it was it was a stand-up
routine I'm not kidding
yeah you said he was like
self-deprecating just like making fun of
him it was a bit of stuff like right and
so if you tell you what man it was a
stand-up routine yeah he would say
something and then he would you know
point out all the Democrats they said
this and they could make a joke yeah and
it was just he was winging it yeah and
everybody was laughing the whole time yo
he was having fun and people feel that
and it's a combination of targeting
their enemies you know keep making them
feel good about their perceived enemy
he's taking a hit you know and him doing
it he can do it so well and then you got
Biden over there he's like hold on I got
I got this approved list of who I'm
allowed to ask is there this person in
the crowd from AP what he did he did
that straight up he said I said I have a
list of who I'm supposed to talk to is
there a so-and-so from AP you know that
this is the re that were that Joe Biden
my goodness is the greatest political
genius of this or any generation I'm
gonna need some serious roof he is
beyond Trump's 40 chest my my word he is
playing five D chess he you see Biden
has studied the art of war he knows he
knows to make mitt you want your enemy
to underestimate you remember yeah we
were saying this earlier about Trump's
rally I said some people were saying
Trump's trying to get them to
underestimate him what we think Biden is
doing the ultimate underestimation yeah
but hold on man I gotta say there was an
ad people were telling us there was a
commercial on our show yep
that Biden it was a Biden ad and in it
he actually gaffes yeah how is it that
Joe Biden ran an ad where he makes a
mistake when they could have just edited
the the mistake out or fixed it right
somebody said to be honest it was
probably an editor going through like
seven hours of footage and then going
like this is the best footage seven
hours of trying and then he just fell
asleep in a corner I think this is what
I got to work with then they put him in
a wheelchair put the little blanket on
his lap and wheeled him into the
sunlight he fell asleep but it doesn't
make me wonder how you get a gaff in an
advertisement right and it could be that
they did like ten takes and they were
like I'll just use these they like
splice them all together but they
couldn't get that word he couldn't say
it yeah or or Joe Biden is the greatest
political genius of this or any
generation yeah and then when they
finally debate he's gonna be like I'm
Joe Biden and I could speak articulately
and clear he's gonna be on so many upper
so these debates we're gonna tap-dance
he's gonna be like I'm Biden he's gonna
be shaking you know they're gonna give
him they're gonna give them the what's
that stuff called that you drink it
makes you immortal adrenochrome ambrosia
oh and ambrosia a drink they're gonna
give him the secret formula man the
lizard people uh-huh and they're gonna
come be like he's gonna be talking and
his skin's gonna like be it gets like
really nice and smooth and you know it's
a little bit let's be real though okay
jokes aside Joe Biden Joe Biden is far
from the greatest anything of any
generation far from it he's pretty good
at make fun of though he's a fumbling
bumbling but that's that's could be a
trick you're right it could be a trick
one of the things I read about the the
cleverness that is Biden is that Trump
was able to go after Hillary on
corruption yeah and she looked very I
guess you could say sharp in the sense
jagged you know serrated pointy like
yeah and so people would see Hillary and
she would be like you know for the
record she still looks like she looks
like I'm saying her demeanor
okay well for the record it's still the
same
the snooze and the snooty eye rolling in
the cackling Hey Joe Biden is fumbling
bumbly Joe Biden yeah how do you make
fun of that he's trying to make him work
corrupt like Joe Biden looks too stupid
to be corrupt well what do you mean a
corrupt I worked and you know the thing
and then it's like this old man you're
threatened by this old man so it dfangs
Trump does because who are you making
fun of the sad old guy sitting in his
wheelchair the sunlight was going on
bowl yes yes yes thank you you're
running as your presidential nominee
absolutely I'm making fun of him and you
know ENC for running him yes yeah it's
like you ever see the prestige yeah
great movie
was it the prestige yeah yeah where the
the the Michael Caine tells the story of
this magic trick where the old man was
like on stage struggling to move and he
had a fishbowl and then he could like
make the fish disappear whatever right
and he's trying and he asks the
magician's like to figure out how he did
it right and then I think it was
Christian Bale or whatever who holds the
fish ball between his legs and explains
that he thinks the real trick was the
old man was weak when he really wasn't
right and the reason he was hobbling was
because he was carrying a fishbowl see
so Joe Biden is milling about bumblin
and fumbling and that debate stage he's
gonna walk out with a cane and he's
gonna trip and fall and then roll on the
ground like Willy Wonka and pop up and
go ah and everyone and then make a
fishbowl up here boom no like you know
the way trust me I know
Gene Wilder is amazing yes I really
would love to meet you if you're
watching I don't do you Wilder he's
alive isn't he no no no my my dreams I'm
pretty sure I know so I'm not saying I
genuinely believe Joe Biden is secretly
holding Becca's you know his years ago
well hey I won well there this is a
message for you I want you to imagine
something miss you I mean I don't know I
don't know how many people who watch
like are familiar with Dragon Ball Z
references not but I'm a anyway I want
you just to imagine Joe Biden's standing
next to trump and then going
and screaming that his hair spikes and
turns gold and his eyes turn you know
cuz they light up eyes are glowing and
then and yeah and then when I popped and
I'm still sad about Gene Wilder he was
probably my first favorite actor in my
life yeah first one that I was like I
like this guy
this guy's great it might have been Dick
Van Dyke actually oh my gosh now that
I'm thinking about Mary Poppins he was
awesome in that movie have you ever seen
the episode of Family Guy where the FCC
censors everything no goodness and that
what life's gonna be like eventually yes
and there's it's so so so that the
episode is Peter creates his own public
access show it was very very offensive
so the absence was to censor everything
and then they're watching TV and they're
like and now back to the beep van beep
show oh right because you can't say Dick
Van Dyke right we might get in trouble
on YouTube just for saying that really
no kidding he's still alive right a
parody has become reality it has become
complete reality thanks for checking out
this clip from the Tim cast IRL podcast
we do the show live Monday through
Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to catch
the full show tune in to this channel
subscribe hit the like button or check
us out on iTunes and Spotify and we will
soon have this podcast up for free on
all podcast platforms thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all in the next
episode
you